das ist mal ein dickes Ding so schön
hier ist das erste deutsche Fernsehen
schönen guten Tag meine Damen und Herren
willkommen bei den Nachrichten heute
packen wir den Adventskalender von
luchest aus und es ist einfach der
größte Kalender
[Musik]
raus was hat er gekostet dieser Kalender
kostet
99,95 € statt
100,83 € man hat also
45,38% gespart aber was ist jetzt
lootchest eigentlich ich meine Marken
wie Rituals oder Klinik sagen uns ja
natürlich was aber gut tschüss passt mal
wenn das Thema denn das sind Mystery
Boxen mit Gaming und nerdsdorf und man
kann sie einzeln kaufen oder einen 300 €
und so weiter und genau dann bekommt man
halt monatlich so Zeug ihr wisst tief im
Herzen bin ich der allergrößte Nerd und
freue mich extrem über diesen Kalender
und den Preis für 100 € finde ich bei
dieser Größe jetzt erstmal okay aber
wirklich gespannt was der jetzt am Ende
drin sein wird und bevor ihr falsche
Gedanken kommt dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses Videos
nicht gefunden laut let's go oh Jo Jo Jo
Jo Jo ein Wort zum Design ich finde es
sehr sehr gut gelungen es gibt ein ultra
weihnachtliches Gefühl die Farben die
Muster alles was er so drinnen ist ist
zehn von zehn es ist ein Kalender den
man aufreißt also nicht wiederverwendbar
und was ich besonders cool finde sind
die
Ornamente für den Tannenbaum z.B das ist
dann hier so ein Pokéball ist oder hier
von Captain America sein Schild äh Luke
Skywalker ist auch da
so wir beginnen Nummer eins boah die
sind das ist alles also alles riesig ich
ich komme damit klar das fängt schon mal
es fängt schon mal mit dem einem
Franchise an mit dem ich nicht ganz so
viel zu tun habe gut ausgedacht ne mit
dieser Größe und so aber
oh mein Gott
Academy es könnte eine gute Tasse für
meinen Bruder sein Statement wenn man
morgens so seine Tasse trinkt ja damit
kann ich jetzt anfangen
experience ein bisschen schwierig
unterschiedliche Preise Moment bei
Amazon habe ich sie gefunden für 14 €,
95 also machen wir 15 € falls euch
irgendwas gefällt und so ich pack alle
Links zu den Produkten dann in die
Infobox Nomad 2 und hier sind alles so
schmale
ging schon mal besser eine offizielle
NASA Powerbank
Kennedy Space Center das ist schon krass
oder so eine Powerbank ich dachte hier
werden nur Tassen und sowas drin sein
22,95 € boah das ist voll teuer ich weiß
nicht ganz genau wann die Verlosung
losgehen aber es könnt ihr
wahrscheinlich dann in dem Kalender in
der Lösung gewinnen okay
äh es ist ein guter Ludwig ich bin jetzt
richtig gespannt was so drin sein wird
Nummer drei oh
yes Harry
Potter ein Puzzle mit 50 Teilen ideal
für zwischendurch also ich Puzzle immer
mit 1000 Teilen deswegen weiß ich gar
nicht wie sich 50 anfühlen aber das ist
cute von Disney gibt's das für 10 €,
also wir nehmen jetzt 10 €, komm nicht
drauf klar das Türchen so groß sind
Nummer vier schon wieder haben wir einen
Rubik's Cube aber dieses mal ist es ein
oh das ist ein Original seht ihr das
hier original Rubiks Cube wir lesen kann
ist klar im Vorteil es ist ein Original
squirsche von Cube der lässt sich nicht
drehen
oh das ist voll schwer
warum sollte man das machen dort auf dem
Bild zerquetsche das richtig und ich
sehr gut dann habt ihr auch noch was
gleich für eure zweijährigen Neffen
die Auswahl an Produkten wird immer
größer dass man es wirklich einfach als
Weihnachtsgeschenke Kalender benutzen
kann acht Euro kostet der 8 € bei
Kaufland 13 53 bei Frohe kostet der
26,95 € als das ist doch über ebay 10
Nummer 5 eine Mystery Box in der Mystery
Box welchen space Jam Charakter hast du
das ist von dem neuen space Jamie
Figuren kann ich irgendwie nicht viel
anfangen weil ich aber eh schon so ein
chaotisches Zimmer habe und jetzt kein
Regal oder so wo ich so gut hinstellen
könnte das ist ein mehr gibt deswegen
werde ich das auf jeden Fall die
verlosungsbox packen und ihr könnt euch
darüber freuen
funko ich machen Zähne sind hier eher
Schätzpreise ne kann auch sein dass ich
mal richtig weit weg liege aber ich sag
mal so das Geschenk für meinen nächsten
Neffen ist gesichert okay
Nikolaus ich schätze ein dass lootchest
richtig was Tolles für Nikolaus
reingepackt hat in unserem Stiefel ist
ich weiß es nicht
Black Widow der taskmaster ja das ist
leider das Problem bei so Mystery Boxen
ne das ist zwar cool so eine Pop Figur
hier und Marvel mag ich eigentlich auch
aber mit dem Task Maske zeige ich ganz
ehrlich kann ich absolut nicht anfangen
das ist mal wieder ein Geschenk für
meine Neffen was kostet noch mal so eine
funko Pop Figur das ist wieder
Interpretationssache nee 16 €, das ist
in zehn damit man das eigentlich um ja
ne also die Leute die das wirklich
sammeln sammeln das doch aus
sammlergründen oder sieben
ich muss jetzt mal gar nicht was es ist
Guardians of the galaxy
zum Spielen absolut also für meinen
Neffen aber ja sind einfach Figuren aus
Metall ne also Spider-Man kriegt man für
13 € Avengers für 20 €. ich mache 15
Nummer 8
eine Brosche
werden sich freuen jetzt kommt das
allerwichtigste Türchen dieses Türchen
ist zwar nicht groß aber in der Nummer 9
steckt immer das Beste drinnen hoffe ich
können das Dungeon und Dragons Würfel
sein
Dragons 5 Euro
gespielt aber das sollten wir gut sein
[Gelächter]
das ist doch was was für ein neues
Türchen The Witcher leider habe ich The
Witcher relativ schnell wieder aufgehört
zu gucken irgendwie hat es mich nicht so
wirklich gekriegt i'm not a Goodman i'm
a Witcher steht hier drauf obwohl
jetzt weiß ich nicht ein bisschen
Schüler dann nimmst du doch keine
Glasflasche mit bricht dir doch sofort
im Rucksack
22,95 € 11 ah ja classic T-Shirt im Wert
von
14,95 € ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht und anstatt ein T-Shirt rein zu
machen zu sagen hey ein T-Shirt im Wert
von 14,95 kannst du hier aussuchen 95
für ein T-Shirt das klingt so wenig nee
den Rest musst du dann halt sagen
natürlich Nummer 12 Halbzeit meine Damen
und Herren klar ein absoluter Klassiker
aber wenigstens ein bisschen
weihnachtlich Socken von Streetfighter
wie Euro aber jetzt wird's was für mich
na
was
okay der Mendel oh lass mal Baby Yoga
drauf okay ich nehme noch mal alles
zurück eigentlich mag ich Star Wars das
neue Star Wars so sieht das aus
ja dann ist es ein leeres Notizbuch aber
sogar mit einer Schnur gleich klingt
Notizbuch erstmal boring aber ich habe
schon im in diesem Bereich gearbeitet
wurden Notizbücher verkauft werden und
und gutes Notizbuch ist ähm wirklich
sehr teuer und ich bin einfach Fechter
von Notizbüchern denn wenn ich mir
Sachen digital aufschreibe dann merke
ich sie mir und verinnerlich sie nicht
so wie wenn ich mit der Hand schreibe
Nummer 14 ist einfach so groß
zwei Türen es wird schon wieder eine
Challenge das hier rauszukriegen
made in China und ansonsten nichts
weiter okay das ist ein bisschen cool
los Polos Hermanos wisst ihr woher das
ist ach von Better call Saul das ist ja
Breaking Bad aber bei der Kurs aber ich
habe zu viele von solchen Bechern in
meinem Leben schon gehabt das ist wie
mit den Beuteln das brauche ich noch mal
extra
hochwertig ne ich sehe hier gerade auf
der Website von denen noch andere und
die sehen halt schon viel viel viel viel
viel viel besser aus ich mache meine
Damen und Herren äh treten sie zurück
denn jetzt ich habe das Gefühl jetzt
kommt das beste natürlich es fängt schon
mal gut an es fängt gut an
wieder am Ende Lorien
Verwechslungsgefahr vorsichtig
cool mein oh mein Gott 9 €
den
ich doch nicht
so ein großes noch mal Doom und auf
jeden Fall shotgläser und ich glaube die
sind extrem cool also diese shotgläser
sind nicht gerade klein aber von der
Verarbeitung sind die toll toll super
toll 15 €, das ist aber nicht für meine
Nichten oh mein Gott das kennen sogar
ich om
i Minecraft figures irgendwie will ich
wissen
painted fegers glow in the dark und
Metal 138 verschiedene die man collecten
kann eine Sache will ich mal öffnen
welche Figuren haben wir wow
wir haben eine
geburtstags mit so oben drauf und ein
glow in the dark ich weiß auch nicht ich
kann zum Beispiel diese Begeisterung für
das wird ja nur so verkauft dass man
nicht weiß was drin ist und es ist ein
bisschen ironisch wenn ich das sage weil
ich sehr viele Mystery Boxen aufmache
aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl man
muss ja dann immer wieder welche kaufen
wenn das so ein richtiges Ding wäre mit
so tauschen dann finde ich das irgendwie
cool weil ich damals das geliebt habe
Sachen zusammen und zu tauschen wenn man
was doppelt hatte die alle könnt ihr
sammeln meldet euch in den Kommentaren
bei mir wenn ihr genau die beiden
braucht
für eine Tüte gemacht 18 geil ein
Handtuch
das ist sporthandtuch Größe ja die
Qualität ist nicht grausam aber so
richtig gut ist die nicht wie sagt man
so lala 19
ich habe keine Geduld mehr dafür dass es
eingepackt ist ohne dass man
ist schon unser viertes Trinkgefäß ein
beschädigtes Deadpool Glas sie dir die
Kratzer da drin die kommt von außen da
ansonsten sind es coole Motive auf dem
Glas sind alles so Bilder gemalt von ihm
wie toll er ist und so dass das finde
ich schon cool aber Kratzer
geht nicht also dann wird immer noch ich
das selber kaputt machen ne und nicht
kaputt bekommen
9,95 nee
nein nein nein so macht man das nicht
stimmt nicht zweimal Deadpool
hintereinander so funktioniert das nicht
und noch ein Stressball oh der
funktioniert aber besser der gefällt mir
besser
als Cube hat man gar nicht zerquette
gekriegt mein Stress Antistress Zeug ist
wichtig ne nicht zwei stressfälle in
einer Adventskalender nun Euro 5,95 ich
glaube ich bin doch nicht so Nerd ich
dachte 21 das ist doch toll mit einer
reusable Case bekommt man allerlei
Pac-Man Zeug ein Anspitzer ein
Kugelschreiber ein Lineal das ist für
Kinder und das ist ein Radiergummi und
links dabei das ist eindeutig für Kinder
7 € 2 und ich oh mein Gott ich dachte
erstmal Minions Spongebob
egal das ist polnische
alles klar
ja das ist mein Spongebob in irgendein
crazy voll geworden wo er einfach zum
Roboter mit sorry leute das ist so
Spongebob Schwammkopf ihr könnt
Wiedersehen
und trotzdem
dreht sich dieses Rad 15 €
schon mal die 23 ist hier jetzt
vielleicht Patrick drin
nein noch eine Trinkflasche das ist Kit
das ist jetzt ist es offiziell eine
Minecraft Trinkflasche das ist für
Kinder erinnert ihr euch noch in diese
Flaschen
sehe also auf jeden Fall aus so einem
metallischen Behälter dann denke ich
immer nur daran dass ich einmal mir
einen Kakao zur Schule machen wollte
weil das ja so cool ist und an dem Tag
hat mein Wasser einfach nach Milch
geschmeckt oder nach Tee oder nach immer
Orangensaft irgendwas Wasser drin war
hat dann einfach diesen Geschmack
übernommen sehen Euro das letzte Türchen
Türchen Nummer 24 und ich bete zu Gott
ist da jetzt obwohl nee ich möchte dass
da jetzt durchgezogen wird und was für
Kinder drin ist
da ist etwas für Kinder drin das ist
jetzt offiziell das ist ein
kinderkalender okay ich habe es
vielleicht einfach falsch verstanden ich
werde euch noch mal gucken bestimmt ist
es einfach ein kinderkalender und dann
macht dieser Kalender plötzlich auch
extrem viel Sinn ich dachte aber das ist
irgendwie für Erwachsene Nerds aber es
ist für Kinder Nerds von fantastic
beasts ab 4 Jahren die niffler-challenge
also man hat irgendwie ein Zauberstab
und dann spielt man da die Münzen müssen
dann nach links und rechts toll ich
gucke jetzt hier mal so was Kinder mäßig
da ist das Handtuch von Sportunterricht
Trinkflasche sorry Stoff auch so ein
Trinkglas eigentlich relativ neutral das
hier finde ich sehr Dings so Notizbuch
hin und Kinder auch gut gebrauchen
allerdings also irgendwie hat mich so
eine Powerbank in eine ganz falsche
Richtung genutzt ich war am Anfang so
überrascht total positiv gestimmt auf
diesen Kalender und dachte mir so ja was
werden denn da noch für krasse Sachen
drin sein ja turns out zwei stressbälle
und eins zwei drei Trinkflaschen zwei
Gläser ja einmal das Depp Punkt Glas und
die shotgläser ein Buch das ist okay
weiß ich nicht also aus einem Grund bin
ich nicht wirklich enttäuscht weil ich
echt coole Geschenke für meine Neffen
habe und ähm ich werde das alles schön
verpacken und dann gibt's ein schönes
Geschenk für die kleinen Mäuse ne jetzt
rechnen wir einmal noch den Preis
zusammen ja und dann sage ich euch meine
Meinung okay crazy also wir haben 100 €
ausgegeben und 2007
75 habe ich da raus also Lucia sagt
selber dass der Inhalt 180 € Wert ist
habe ich dann am Anfang falsch aber ich
habe wirklich alles nachgeschaut also
ich finde es gut ich bin ich finde es
gut dass da quasi nach meiner Rechnung
noch viel mehr rausgekommen ist als sie
eigentlich selber unsicht behauptet
haben also auch wenn ich jetzt teilweise
so rumgemeckert habe finde ich den
Kalender halt 1A für junge Erwachsene
Schrägstrich Kinder das was mir am
meisten angesprochen hat weil das Harry
Potter Puzzle und die shotgläser und das
ist schon ein bisschen bezeichnend oder
ja
nein ja doch also hätte ich meinen
Nerven diesen Kalender gekauft wäre das
ein absoluter win gewesen und man kriegt
ja anscheinend für 100 € ziemlich viele
Sachen jetzt ist halt die Frage ob man
diese Sachen auch wirklich braucht ne
weil wenn man Leck Widow eigentlich
nicht sammelt dann hat man jetzt einfach
eine Sache von Black Bilder und dann
kann man die halt versuchen loszuwerden
zu verkaufen für günstiger hin und
hergerissen aber das ist halt das ist
das allgemeine viel mit Mystery Boxen ne
kaufen ohne zu wissen was man kauft ist
ja bei Adventskalendern der wirklich
Sinn dahinter bzw kann man ja schon
sehen was da drin also ne aber ich meine
gibt es eh nicht mehr also ist meine
Empfehlung Figur wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Mal wieder ciao